et pour en parler nous sommes avec marie
claire cailletaud dirigeante confédéral
cgt à bonsoir madame merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france à ses
côtés christian saint-palais avocat
merci à vous aussi
m d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc huitième journée de
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
beaucoup moins de monde dans les rues
par rapport aux autres manifestations on
imagine que ça devient peut-être
compliqué pour les salariés de prendre à
chaque fois des jours pour aller
manifester ce qui n'entame certainement
pas la détermination en tout cas au vu
des sondages qui donnent toujours une
majorité de français contre ce projet de
réforme comment vous expliquer en tout
cas cette baisse de participation dans
les rues déjà moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que la mobilisation elle ne
compte pas uniquement au nombre de
manifestants il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passent dans pillain qui sont pas
forcément tout médiatisé maintenant
beaucoup de professions bon dans le
secteur de l'énergie dans dans le
secteur ports et docks de métal
métallurgie enfin dans beaucoup
d'endroits il se passe des choses est
effectivement bon les manifestations
sont peut-être inégal c'est vrai que
c'est on s'appelle par exemple
qu'aujourd'hui manifesté mercredi c'est
moins simple par rapport aux enseignants
ou voilà ou aux jeunes et évidemment ça
finit par compter quand on a des payes
qui arrivent avec des chiffres de zéro
voire négatif avec le prélèvement à la
source des impôts il ya des fois aussi
compliqué on est obligé de reprendre le
travail mais ça veut pas dire que la
détermination n'est pas là je pense que
détermination est vraiment ancrée ancrée
chez les grévistes chez les salariés et
puis un fait quand même extraordinaire
qui états unis c'est l'opinion publique
continue à tenir et à rejeter
massivement ce projet de loi ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir trouver
d'autres formes d'action être créatif
dans la nuque parce que le gouvernement
de l'autre côté semble déterminé à
continuer d'ailleurs le texte a débuté
son parcours législatif alors
l'intersyndicale se réunit en ce moment
donc je pense qu'elle va sortir avec l'
annonce d'une journée d'action
certainement la semaine prochaine nous
réfléchissons aussi à des actions
effectivement différente pour pouvoir
tenir dans la durée
beaucoup de choses sont débattus à
l'heure actuelle au niveau de la cgt
nous pensons lancer notre propre
conférence de financement de manière
très ouverte beaucoup plus ouverte que
le gouvernement pour montrer que les
propositions que nous faisons pour un
système de retraite solidaire et de haut
niveau pour tous il est possible il est
crédible et il est finançable
voilà beaucoup de choses sans discussion
et effectivement moi je suis effaré par
l'attitude du gouvernement qui dit
grosso modo on vient entendre le premier
ministre à l'assemblée
je fais comme si se passait rien
continue enfin quand même ils auraient
pu au moins pu est alerté par ce qu'a
dit le conseil d'état le conseil d'état
c'est pas rien quand conseil d'état dit
que l'étude d'impact 20 qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une étude d'impact pour un
projet de loi c'est une étude qui dit
quelles vont être les conséquences du
projet de loisir que ce qu'est ce que ça
va donner pour la vie des gens et quand
conseil d'état dit que l'étude d'impact
est lacunaire qu'elle n'est pas
suffisante qu'elle n'est pas solide d'un
point de vue juridique et qu' elle
critique le fait que 29 ordonnance vont
être faites ce projet de loi 29 c'est
énorme pour le travail avec 27 et 29 ans
demain ça veut dire qu'ils vont avoir
valeur de loi qui ne rendons pas d'étude
d'impact et le conseil d'état note que
c'est pour une loi qui a une hauteur
inédite depuis 45 parce qu'elle remet en
cause une partie importante du contrat
social des français vous voyez ça c'est
que c'est quand même des choses qui
devrait alerter le gouvernement nous
avait un peu plus de modestie et
pourrait on va renvoyer aux nières
effectivement m christian saint palais
ou alors sauf erreur de ma part j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes une des
seules professions avec fonds de réserve
très important pour l'instant n'avoir
pas obtenu gain de cause à ce que le
pouvoir de nuisance n'a pas été assez
grand avec vos grèves ralentir les
affaires on a vu les danseurs les
pompiers les pilotes les navigants dans
leur ensemble qu'ils ont obtenu voilà
des des aménagements c'est toujours pas
votre cas vous n'avez rien obtenu pour
l'instant même si on parlera évidemment
de la ministre qui a été rassurante
concernant les avocats ce matin ou et
n'êtes peut-être obligé de les croire
non je crois qu'elle a voulu être
rassurant de marfin de personnes nées du
si vous examinez un peu les messages sur
les réseaux sociaux tout le monde et
même très heurtée par ce discours qui
fait fi de toutes les objections que
nous avons formulées vous disiez tout à
l'heure que notre régime effectivement
dispose de réserves
on leur a peut-être tout à l'heure c'est
une caisse autonome ce n'est pas un
régime spécial mais gérée par les
avocats pilotes et navigants nous avons
notre régime autonome créée par nous
seuls pour la retraite de base et la
retraite complémentaire c'est ça la
grande spécificité gym d'avocats qui
nous nous avons déjà créé les conditions
d'égalité on dit aujourd'hui que l'on
veut créer l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes chez les avocats nous avons
déjà atteint cet objectif avec une
retraite minimum garantis quelles
qu'aient été les chaos dans la vie
professionnelle quelles qu'aient été les
heures de vie
les accidents de parcours 1450 euros
garantis le projet qu'on nous propose
aujourd'hui ses 1000 euros minimum vous
voyez nous allons y perd et nous avons
aussi parce qu'on peut se dire mais vous
voulez garder votre régime autonome les
avocats voulaient rester entre vous
entre non petit vous avez cotisé à
accumuler alors je pense qu'on sera
mieux gardées il ya 2 milliards en
vérité de réserve mais je veux dire
quand même que ce régime a été toujours
solidaire du régime général est que nous
versons par an 92 à 98 millions d'euros
au régime général c'est-à-dire par
avocat et par an 1250 euros
il faut pas croire et ou laisser dire
parce que c'est un peu l'image qu'ils
essaieraient d'entretenir que nous
serions de notre côté que nous voudrions
rester entre nantis alors que vous savez
il faut le souligner que la profession
d'avocat revêt une diversité tout à fait
étonnante avec beaucoup de confrères et
consoeurs jeune ou pas d'ailleurs qui
ont atteint un revenu faible revenu tout
à fait modeste et qui donnent leur temps
leur énergie leurs compétences et leurs
talents au service des plus démunis de
notre société sans avoir d'honoraires
très important alors la ministre de la
justice chez nos confrères d'europe 1 ce
matin voulait est rassurante
effectivement elle a donné des exemples
assez concret pour un avocat qui gagnent
autour de 32000 euros par an les
pensions vont passer selon elle de 2002
170 euros à 2500 euros par mois dont
elle ne baisse pas a dit fonctions les
ministres
vrai ou faux alors justement là nous
sommes je crois comme tous les citoyens
français dans un flou de chiffres de
mensonges de chiffres vous savez il ya
beaucoup de chiffres qui ont été avancés
avec celui que l'on appelait l'avocat
françois qui démarrerait en première
année à l'âge de 28 ans avec 46 mille
euros et alors vous verrez que partout
les avocats disent mais on cherche
françois ceux qui veulent se marier avec
françois cherche ce françois parce qu'il
n'existe pas c'est un cas utopique qui
est présenté pour nous faire croire que
cette réforme aurait des incidences
extraordinaire alors ce que je pense
d'ailleurs c'est que peut-être vous
disiez tout à l'heure mais vos actions
sont elles suffisamment nuisibles
puisque c'est quand même ça qu'il faut
trouver un pouvoir d' alerte en tout cas
pour
est-ce qu'elles le sont suffisamment
quand on voit que rien ne bouge je pense
que nous avons un effort à faire nous
mêmes pour contredire les chiffres qui
sont avancés qui sont des chiffres faux
qui en tout cas ne sont pas étayées et
qui créent tous les avocats qui crée une
situation pour tous les avocats de
grandes inquiétudes
et c'est terrible d'être inquiet quand
je vois les jeunes et qui rentre dans la
profession et qui sont inquiets pour
l'avenir
on leur dit vous allez cotiser davantage
et nous ne pouvons pas cotiser davantage
c'est ça ce qu'il faut comprendre pour
les avocats on leur dit vous avez un
prélèvement hauteur de 14 % de votre
revenu pour la retraite et désormais
vous allez passer à 28 parce que ça
c'est une réalité et nous avons un très
grand nombre ce n'est pas un doublement
puisque nous allons baisser les
cotisations retraite elle pas
précisément de ce x 2 de cotisation mais
elle pourrait lé voilà ce n'est pas un
doublement
alors c'est un doublement dans le projet
initial est aujourd'hui puisque bisons
et nous manifestons que nous ne voulons
pas ce qui ce qui a été prévu par le
gouvernement
alors aujourd'hui on nous dit mais on va
diminuer ailleurs on va diminuer pas
dans quelles conditions avec quelle
pérennité quelles garanties pour
l'avenir
rien bien sûr rien c'est pour ça que
nous disons laissez-nous non laissez
nous donc gérer notre système de
retraite comme nous avons su le faire
vraiment je vous assure que quand on
vous dit il n'y a pas d'étude d'impact
suffisante c'est le conseil d'état qui
le dit c'est parce que quand nous
connaissons la situation d'une
profession nous voyons bien dans ce qui
est proposé que rien des chiffres est
rien et on anticipe et rien n'est
vraiment programmé
rien n'est étayé dans les promesses ce
qu'ils sont marie claire cailletaud
edouard philippe a rassuré au sénat
n'avoir pas peur du débat parlementaire
à l'assemblée au sénat ceux qui disent
que ce débat on l'a entendu un tout à
l'heure devrait prendre la forme d'un
champ de braise ne disent pas quelque
chose auquel je crois il promet un vrai
débat parlementaire on imagine que vous
n'avez plus confiance c'est vrai que
pour le moment le gouvernement ne recule
pas il ya la rue les différentes
professions il ya les différents partis
politiques les parlementaires qui sont
en fronde
vous avez clairement peur aujourd'hui
tous les deux d'ailleurs d'un passage en
force de l'exécutif
non mais c'est clair il a beau jeu de
dire qu'il n'a pas peur d'un débat
parlementaire mais je veux dire bon
quand on voit l'assemblée telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
effectivement moi je suis franchement
effrayé que des députés soient prêtes à
voter un texte alors qu'il ya des trous
dedans enfin c'est quand même une
première on sait la majorité cpm et de
se faire exclure de leur parti non mais
d'accord mais à un moment donné je
trouve qu'il faut être sérieux quand ils
sont dix représentants de la nation ils
sont élus ils y voient là et tous vous
attend des données la république en
marche alors responsabilités bien sûr
aujourd'hui en un conseil d'état qui dit
que l'étude d'impact ne sécurise pas le
texte juridiquement juridiquement et
quand elle dit qu'en plus le fait
d'avoir 29 ordonnance derrière 29
ordonnance ne donne pas de lisibilité et
que c'est un texier extrêmement
important parce qu'il va modifier
profondément contrat social des français
c'est quand même pas possible que des
députés acceptent acceptent de voter un
tel texte
parce qu'effectivement il a beau jeu de
dire ça va se passer on va passer en
force et dans deux mots dans trois mois
c'est plié
mais si c'est ça qu'il a dans la tête le
chambon le chante brel moi je ne
souhaite pas bien évidemment je ne
souhaite pas mais il est responsable le
gouvernement actuel est responsable
chante breizh quand il ya une majorité
de la population enfin ils ont la bouche
pleine du mot démocratie aujourd'hui
regardons quand même une majorité de la
population est contre ce projet de loi
une majorité d'organisations syndicales
kirpan une majorité de saintes de
syndiqués et contre ce projet de loi de
salariés durement donner la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement élu
c'est de dire je fais une pause je fais
une pause rameau projet les mâles gros
salaires ou mais ben voilà nous faisons
plus de pédagogie mais j'aime pas du
tout ça mais au contraire ils font ce
qu'il continue à foncer et donc s'il ya
quand même à un véritable moi je pense
qu'ils apprennent des vous disiez que
l'on alors que la cgt allait faire sa
propre conférence de bilan cement on le
sent que la cgt philippe martinez en
tout cas va participer à la conférence
de financement qui s'ouvre vendredi avec
les autres syndicats c'est bien le cas
vous confirmer alors la conférence de
financement elle s'ouvre demain
et oui la question et c'est que on sait
pas ce qu'il ya dedans parce que si vous
voulez pour l'instant le ce qu'on sait
c'est que ça va être une réunion de
trois heures de 14h30 à 17h30 le premier
ministre va parler mais d'une part donc
c'est quand même visiblement une grosse
opération de communication
néanmoins la cgt sera présente elle n'a
jamais fait là
vide donc elle sera présente mais si
vous voulez ce qui a été annoncé par le
gouvernement par un ministre c'est qu'on
avait un cadre extrêmement contrainte
dire qu'on rentre dans une boîte et puis
visiblement il n'y a qu'une porte de
sortie c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
parler d'augmentation des cotisations
sociales on peut pas parler des
exonérations de cotisations des
entreprises enfin voilà il ya beaucoup
de sujets qui sont à bout qui font que
de fait la sortie et réfléchi sur
l'augmentation du temps de travail donc
il faut pas prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles non plus donc rentrer dans un
tel tunnel donc nous on va y aller
demain mais en fait vous demander le
retrait d'une ex donc c'est vrai que
vous m la marge de manoeuvre a prédominé
entouraient la tente est là et non non
non non parce que nous on venait des
propositions et donc demain on va mettre
sur la table nos propositions parce
qu'on dit cui il faut que le système il
évolué pour prendre en compte tous les
nouveaux métiers pour prendre en compte
justement les carrières qui sont h f il
ya beaucoup de situations qui doivent
notre système doit être amélioré et on a
des propositions pour l'améliorer et si
on va les mettre à table demain mais
comment fait depuis deux ans et
malheureusement
visiblement on n'est pas du tout entendu
et sans s'appeller vous attendez quelque
chose vous de cette conférence de
financement d'un dock la cfdt est le
seul syndicat qui est assez d'accord
avec ce système universel à poser quand
même ces conditions avancées dans la
justice sociale pour donner du sens à
cette réforme avant de discuter de cet
équilibre des comptes vous attendez
quelque chose vous les avocats de cette
grande réunion demain
non nous sommes sur un sujet je dirais
plus circonscrire notre profession mais
il ya de quoi être inquiet parce que
quand on l'entend
nous allons gagner au parlement c'est
une équipe qui est s'est fait élire en
disant nous allons changer les pratiques
gouvernementales les pratiques de
gouvernance les députés godillots
on a connu c'est la cinquième république
ça n'est pas nouveau et ce qui est
vraiment très préoccupant c'est de voir
ces jeunes députés jeudi jeunes mais en
tout cas en tant que député quel que
soit leur âge sybille leur état civil
ces jeunes et député qui rempile dans
des pratiques mais vraiment qu'ils ne
sont pas glorieuses et qui sont même
honteuse c'est à dire de nairas
peut-être les ont signés pour la
république en marche et le même emmanuel
macron qui s'est fait élire avait promis
réforme du système universel à point
alors voilà pas de l'âge mais on vous
dira peut-être mais je sais quel jeu
c'est l'argument mais vous savez
parfaitement que dans le projet
présidentiel
rien de ce qui est aujourd'hui sur la
table n'étaient promis et aucun des
électeurs n'a eu le sentiment même les
plus les plus proches de ce programme
mais le principe de la bien sûr de la
retraite à points mais jamais par
exemple jamais aucun avocat qui a voté
pour la république en marche et il y en
eut beaucoup mais jamais aucun n'a
adhéré à un projet de réforme de la
retraite par exemple et donc ce qui est
très préoccupant c'est d'avoir le
sentiment que ça va être gouvernés de
force parce qu'on veut absolument avoir
comme ce calme c'est à dire il va
falloir montrer que l'on est capable
d'avancer ce que les autres
gouvernements distille n'ont pas su
faire
et donc je vous dit que demain s'ouvre
une obtention des conférences de
financement mais oui nous sommes
inquiets parce qu'on se dit mais quels
sont les arguments qui vont être
entendus je crois que ce qu'il savait
faire
c'est techniquement mettre les gens
autour de la table et offrir des
postures des coupes des postures
physiques intenses de l'artisan
désengageant syndicats nous disent
qu'ils les avocats sont allés écouter ce
que le premier ministre avait à leur
dire ce week-end et ils sont ressortis
nos représentants sont ressortis en nous
disant mais enfin il ya eu un communiqué
du premier ministre et la présidente
christiane féral-schuhl du cnb qui est
donc notre organe représentatif a écrit
nous a écrit pour nous dire mais j'ai
l'impression que nous n'étions pas à la
même réunion
donc si vous voulez techniquement pour
l'image il y a de la concertation et sur
le fond il y a aussi une écoute pendant
la réunion j'ai assisté à des réunions
non pas sur la retraite mais sur
d'autres réunions sur la réforme des
lois sur la justice où on nous écoute et
parfois d'ailleurs nos interlocuteurs
sont de qualité mais ensuite on trace le
chemin qui avaient été fixés et rien ne
peut les faire dévier et surtout ici la
colère du peuple parce que c'est ça que
nous sommes nous sommes le peuple dans
la rue nous nous venons dire nous ne
voulons pas de ce que vous nous proposez
rien n'y fait maître vous qui êtes
voilà c'est par définition juriste la
mise en garde du conseil d'état avec ses
quatre groupes d'opposition qui ont
demandé une saisine du conseil
constitutionnel aux sujets de l'étude
d'impact jugée incomplète est insincère
est-ce que ça ça peut être une porte de
sortie crédibles endroit flambeau disais
tout à l'heure
est-ce que alors que le débat
parlementaire s'ouvre est ce qu'on a des
raisons d'espérer quand même que être
entendu moi je crois à la force de
l'état de droit
oui il ne faut jamais désespérer
tailleur de l'état de droit le conseil
d'état a dit ce qu'il avait à dire
mais dans le cadre qui était le sien il
ne peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin
jamais sans doute n'est-il aller aussi
loin pour exprimer les critiques sur un
texte
alors il a dit ce qu'il avait à dire
mais il ne peut pas nous faire retirer
le texte ni la nuit nous ne sommes pas
là un jour le conseil constitutionnel
sera vraisemblablement saisie avant la
promulgation de la loi par des députés
des sénateurs 60 que parlementaire et
allons nous verrons lors je ne désespère
pas mais il faut encore que cette loi
viole un principe constitutionnel une
règle constitutionnelle
vous savez il ya aussi des traders très
particulier au magazine mais là nous
verrons
je crois vraiment d'ailleurs les
juristes vont s'appliquer à proposer aux
députés les recours qu'il y aura lieu de
faire mais avant espérons que le travail
parlementaire a quand même non marie
claire cailletaud pour finir les
prochaines actions justement vous avez
dit à une intersyndicale ce soir mais
que reste t'il effectivement si le
gouvernement devait rester sourd et muet
vos attentes
a tous je pense que toute façon là la
colère elle continue donc elle est
vraiment très ancrée un franc
franchement et donc les gens vont
trouver des formes de mobilisation pour
durer vous savez ils sont très inventif
dans les grèves ils sont très inventif
il ya beaucoup d'exemples qu on pourrait
citer mais donc je pense que les actions
vont continuer on a d'ailleurs eu des
méthodes jugées contestables de la part
de la cgt
on a déjà parlé ensemble sur ce coup là
il ya encore eu beaucoup de coupures
aujourd'hui vous savez il ya eu quand
même 14 8 mégawatts qui ont été retirés
sur le réseau aujourd'hui on se rend pas
compte parce que ça c'est pas des
coupures mais c'est énorme c'est énorme
donc il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup d'action
aujourd'hui encore et il va continuer à
avoir des actions qu'on va trouver je
pense les salariés ils veulent de toute
façon ils sont persuadés que ce projet
est mauvais parce que il va contribuer
ce qu'ils travaillent plus longtemps et
qu'ils aient moins la retraite donc de
toute façon moi je leur fais confiance
ils vont trouver des formes d'action
pour pouvoir continuer à exprimer leur
mécontentement lundi
tous les avocats sont appelés à
rejoindre paris lundi et je peux vous
dire que les bus et les trains sont déjà
plaints parce que les avocats veulent
absolument montrer d'abord que nous
sommes unis et que nous sommes
d'éternels vont être on peut terminer
d'ailleurs il nous reste une minute
finalement on peut que rester avec vous
et déterminer quelles vont être les
prochaines actions justement des avocats
est ce que vous allez continuer
effectivement a fait recette
cette grève qui bloque tous les jours
les abris tous les jours les avocats
nous sollicitons les renvois des
affaires les tribunaux jusqu'à présent
tu des zoreils assez attentive à nos
revendications mais maintenant ça se
crispe de plus en plus mais il ne faut
pas compter sur l'usure des avocats
c'est très compliqué de faire grève
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il faut
que nous expliquons d'abord aux juges
que nous ne voulons pas plaider à nos
clients qui attendent de la résolution
de leurs litiges que nous ne voulons pas
plaider parce que nous faisons grève et
les avocats ne perçoivent pas les
honoraires c'est difficile mais nous
sommes à ce point déterminé et je dirais
grâce à des mouvements parfois
enthousiaste quand on voit ce que fait
le barreau de bobigny via les confrères
et consoeurs qui sortent absolument je
dirais magique parce qu'il faut arriver
à redonner le moral à ceux qui sont
grévistes et il arriva le données dont
nous sommes déterminés et nous allons
commencer à faire gripper la machine ce
qu'on nous reproche parfois mais ce qui
est absolument indispensable et je
regrette que le gouvernement nous
conduisent à ces actions là je le
regrette je le déplore c'est très
douloureux pour nous de refuser de
plaider il ya des avocats qui jettent
leurs robes ne savais pas ce que ça
représente 7 inédite à morcellement une
voie d d'ailleurs c'est vrai
irez vous soyez d'accord les cgt avocats
en général pourquoi il ya tant de
secteurs qui se mobilisent cette fois
s'interroger
merci en tout cas tous les deux marie
claire cailletaud donc de la cgt
christian saint-palais avocat d'être
venu avec nous pour parler de cette
réforme des retraites alors que la
conférence de financement s'ouvre demain
merci à vous dans quelques